one of Humanity's great Traditions is
for older people to complain about the
work ethic of younger people we've seen
this pattern repeat with every
generation in modern history and we
would probably see something similar if
we could go back to a time before modern
history it seems likely that if you talk
to uh I don't know 45-year-old in the
year 1200 BC they would tell you that
kids those days are a bunch of lazy
ungrateful wh Whipper Snappers in fact
we don't have to speculate about this we
know that Aristotle some 300 years
before Christ complained that young
people of the day were High minded and
had not yet been humbled by life
meanwhile the Roman poet Horus in the
1st Century BC chastised young people as
beardless and accuse them of squandering
their money which tells us that the
epidemic of beardless men goes all the
way back to ancient Rome which is kind
of a shocking and troubling Discovery
the point is that there's there's
there's nothing new Under the Sun and
complaints by old fogies like myself
directed at the youth certainly are no
exception to that rule however just
because a complaint is common that
doesn't make it necessarily invalid in
fact if anything it would seem to
suggest the opposite and these days when
it comes to concerns over a lack of work
ethic among the current crop of young
adults all signs indicate that the
concerns are well founded you know I
don't know if they were true in Rome or
Greece 2,000 years ago but I know that
here in the year 2023 we do seem to have
a problem and it is a serious problem
time reported in 2021 that young people
are leaving their jobs in record numbers
and many of them are not getting new
jobs at all this trend doesn't seem to
have slowed down at the beginning of
this year CNBC reported that 70% of gen
Z and Millennials are planning to leave
their jobs and of course 70% is a large
number plenty of them will get new jobs
or try to but the number of young adults
who have no job and are not in school
has been trending upwards as of 2022
over half of jenzi adults are living at
home with their parents uh the
statistics are pretty familiar to most
people goes on and on we get the idea
but the issue isn't simply jenzi
refusing to get jobs it's how they
behave once they have the job a survey
of 1300 employers and managers revealed
a significant consensus among uh uh
these employers that this current group
of young adults tend to be extremely
difficult in the workplace the New York
Post reports quote some American
business owners and managers hold a
dismal view of genz workers shocking new
research has revealed Resume Builder
surveyed uh 1,344 people in managerial
positions across different Industries in
the US earlier this month asking them
about their experiences working with
those born in 1997 or later almost half
49% of respondents declared it difficult
to work with genz all or most of the
time while a staggering 79% said they
find them to be the most difficult
generation to have in the workplace of
that majority 59% said that they have
have had to fire gen Z employees and 20%
20% even claim to have asked one of the
young workers within a week of their
start date managers and owners commonly
ided entitlement and a lack of effort
motivation and productivity as reasons
why they were given the boot now this
brings to mind all of the genz Le Trends
we've discussed on this show quiet
quitting and bare minimum Mondays and
resen ISM Etc all just trendier and
slightly more subtle ways of describing
laziness and it's not always subtle
though the quiet quitting Trend uh has
recently been supplanted by loud
quitting which is exactly what it sounds
like here's a Tik Tok video promoting
this fun new
fad hey I'm going to need you to come
back early from your break it's crazy
out there oh no sorry I'm actually
applying to jobs right now I'm super
busy trying to make sure I never have to
come back here again what
why oh because I'm miserable mainly
because of you you're the
worst excuse me if I had a dollar for
every time you make me question my
sanity I think think I'd be retired and
be able to escape this Perpetual state
of misery okay so that's what loud
quitting looks like it's when you quit
loudly apparently now just to be clear
the good guy in that scenario is
supposed to be the grading obnoxious and
disrespectful employee she's meant to be
like the sympathetic character in this
little skit which perhaps tells you
everything you need to know I guess and
of course the quiet quitters and Loud
quitters and bare minimum monders have
excuses for their lack ofical approach
as Business Insider reported a few weeks
ago jenz and employees say that um uh
their perceived laziness can be
explained by the fact that they feel
unfulfilled at work that they are burned
out that they are unhappy with their
wages that they're looking for a better
work life balance or some combination of
these excuses but whether the excuses
are valid or not and we'll get to that
in a moment uh it seems that even many
Jers themselves will not not deny their
General lack of effort it's just that
they think they have a good reason for
it and that brings us to this extremely
viral video that if you spend any time
on social media uh you've likely already
seen it over the last day or two in the
video we hear a young woman giving her
perspective on her first nto5 job and
she is to put it mildly not thrilled
with it watch I know I'm probably just
being so dramatic and annoying but this
is my first job like my first 9 to5 job
after college and I'm in person and I'm
commuting in the city and it takes me
forever to get there there's no way I'm
going to be able to afford living in the
city right now so that's off the table
like du if I was able to walk to work
and it it'd be fine but I'm not so it
literally takes me like I leave here
like I get on the train at 7:30 and I
don't get home till like 6:15 earliest
and then like I don't have time to do
anything I don't I want to shower eat my
dinner and go to sleep I don't have time
or energy to cook by dinner either like
I don't have energy to work out like
that's out the window like I'm so upset
oh my God nothing to do with my job at
all but just like the 9 9 to 5 schedule
in general is crazy being in the office
9 to 5 like if it was remote you get off
at 5:00 and you're home and everything's
fine but like I'm not home it takes me
long to get home and like like people
that drive to the office like it doesn't
you don't get off at 5: and I know it
could be worse I know I could be working
longer but like I literally get off it's
pitch black like I don't have energy how
do you have friends like how do you have
time to like meet like a guy I don't
know like how do you have time for like
dating like I don't have time for
anything and I'm like so stressed out
and now as always with these viral
videos the story isn't really the video
itself but the general reaction to it
and from what I've seen although there
are some people telling her to stop
whining and get to work a large
percentage of people uh seemingly on the
left and right have taken her side and
and are scolding those who are
criticizing her they say that she's
entirely justified in being so upset
about the 9 to-5 grind that the work
hours the lifestyle the commute are
indeed very difficult if not completely
Soul crushing and according to this side
of the discussion those being
unsympathetic to this young lady are uh
needlessly cruel and
heartless meanwhile plenty of young
people about her age have chimed in to
Echo her complaints and they say they're
done with the 9 to-5 routine it's time
to abolish it for good last month the
G20 announced a plan to impose digital
currencies and digital IDs on their
respective populations Central Bank
digital currencies allow the government
to track every purchase you made they
could even give officials the ability to
prohibit you from purchasing certain
items or freeze your account altogether
there's reason to be concerned about
this you know to put them mildly if you
haven't yet you need to call Birch gold
today and talk to an expert about
preserving your savings in a tax
sheltered retirement account if you have
an IRA or 401K from a previous employer
and all it's doing is just Gathering
dust we'll call Birch gold and they'll
help you convert it into an IRA in Gold
you won't pay a penny out of pocket
they'll simply convert that 401k into a
physical gold which unlike digital
currency can't be tampered with text
Walsh to 9898 98 and sorry I said that
wrong text Walsh to 98 9898 and Birch
gold will send you a free info kit on
gold if digital currency becomes a
reality you'll be glad you have
something physical to fall back on text
Walsh to 98 9898 and claim your free
info kit on gold
today okay well here's what I say and a
few points about this first of
all I personally would not want to work
a 9o5 corporate job e even if it was a 9
to noon corporate job and my commute was
10 minutes and I was paid a million
dollars I would find it unbearable now
nothing against the people who work
those kinds of jobs if that's how you
feed your family more power to you if
you find a way to be fulfilled in it
even better but for me personally I
think I'd rather be in a prison camp so
um I understand anyone who sits in a
cubicle all day and laments it I would
lament it too but the thing is that um
the thing that's often missing from the
Jens Z Lamentations about the modern
working world is any discussion about
the Alternatives it's not just gen Z
it's like anytime anyone is complaining
about the modern Working World okay what
are the
Alternatives uh and if someone is
especially for young people who are
saying this is so difficult I don't want
to do it it's very important to quickly
transition that complaint into a all
right well you don't like that here's
what else you could do now as I so often
preach we all well most of us have to
work life is work work comes in many
forms but no matter what if you are like
the vast majority of humans who have
ever lived on earth then you will have
to pick some form of work life requires
work to sustain there's no way around
this outside of enslaving others and
forcing them to do all the work for you
so if you're not going to be a slave
owner then you're left with working and
if you don't want to jump on the
nto5 uh racket then there are some other
options
and here they
are one if you're a woman you can become
a stay-at-home mom and it is certainly
not a coincidence that so many of these
Tik Tok videos of people complaining
about hustle culture and the daily
corporate grind feature women not all of
them but like most of the time if we
play a video like this on the show you
notice it's you these are usually women
and that's
because you know the the gender angle
cannot be ignored here although it often
is women are not not wired for this the
way that men are that's the reality
whether we want to admit it or not what
many women actually desire even if they
feel they aren't allowed to articulate
that desire what they actually desire is
to be mothers and homemakers the drive
to leave the home and ruthlessly compete
to earn a living that is an inherently
masculine Drive lots of women simply
don't have that in them and and that is
not a bad thing it's not like they're
lacking something they're just different
and so I wouldn't respond to a video
like that by saying no go out and be a
corporate girl boss it's what you're
meant to do that's not my
message men and women are
different women are women they're not
men so if this push against the
nine-to-five grind leads more women to
embrace their calling as wives and
mothers that's a great thing but there
is a caveat here okay being a
stay-at-home mom is work it's not a job
it's not a job but it is work and in
fact it requires a lot more work than
the average 9 to5 job that's partly
because the work begins much earlier
than 9 unless you are incredibly blessed
and your kids sleep till 9: um but
probably the work begins much earlier
than 9: and it goes much later than five
as I said life is work leaving the 9 to5
behind does not mean leaving work behind
in many cases it means more work harder
work more exhausting work work with much
more on the line a lot more pressure the
good news is that the work is more
fulfilling and more important but it is
work all the
same two the second option you can get a
job outside of the 9-to-5 structure that
you know the easiest version of this
option would be a remote job the only
problem is that many companies are
trending away from a remote work also if
you choose to work from home and you do
care about climbing the ladder in your
industry you'll likely be hindered by
the lack of physical in-person
interaction with your co-workers and
bosses I mean when it comes down to it
like we we Society tried this for a
couple of years and uh what we
discovered is that many jobs really
cannot be performed at a high level when
you're sitting at your home in your
pajamas there are still some jobs like
that if you get one of those jobs then
good for
you um but most people
won't so the so you know the next part
of that option is you could leave the
corporate world behind entirely and you
could become an entrepreneur or you
could pursue a career in a in a creative
industry an industry where the 9-to-5 is
not relevant that's what I decided to do
I've never once regretted it in my life
but you know as I said desks and
cubicles and busy work have just never
been my strong suit uh if I had a
corporate job maybe I would be crying
about it on Tik Tok too but again there
is the
caveat um that this path will almost
always require far far more work the
ninto five setup is irrelevant in my
line of work but that's because I work a
whole lot more than 8 hours a day for me
it's more like 12 or 13 hours a day in
fact in my business you're basically
always on the clock I wouldn't trade it
for a corporate job under any
circumstance um which is probably a good
thing because no Corporation would touch
me with a 10- foot pole at this point
but it is more work ultimately so if
your if your fundamental complaint is
you don't want to do the work you don't
want to work or you want more free time
then the second option really isn't good
either three finally if you're done with
capitalism and the modern Working World
entirely as many gen zers claim to B
they say we're done with all of this
it's all it's all a societal human
construct 9 to5 we don't need
it okay well there is a way around that
too this is the third option it's really
your only real option if you're
completely done with all of this you can
get away from it all you can drop out of
modern society to the extent that it's
possible to do such a thing you can move
out to the Wilderness somewhere and you
could try to live a self-sustaining life
build your own home grow your own food
hunt fish you know all of that and I
mean this is how nearly everybody lived
before the invention of the N9 to5 and
the way to reject that modern system
entirely is to go back to a
pre-industrial lifestyle which which is
still technically possible there are
people who do it maybe like five people
but there are people who do it but this
out of all the options will be by far in
way the hardest and require the most
amount of work that's because people
prior to the Industrial Age worked
essentially every minute of every day
sun up to sun down with no breaks on
weekends and no federal
holidays I would greatly admire anyone
who attempted to live this way today but
if you're doing it because you want more
free time well you're going to be in for
a very unfortunate
surprise now if you don't want any of
these options you don't want to be a
stay-at home mom you don't want to work
in an industry outside of the 9 to-5
system you don't want to be a Pioneer
out in the woods well then the corporate
slog is all you have left that or
winning the lottery but you're not going
to win the lottery so the corporate slog
is it now as you've probably noticed
that slog may be a slog but it's also
the easiest and least arduous path and
requires the least amount of work and
gives you the most free time out of all
the
possibilities you know you you notice in
that video she talks about I go to work
at 7:30 I get home at 6
7:30 to 6 well that leaves you you know
you could have four hours of free time
go to bed at 10
p.m. uh sleep for 8 hours wake up in the
morning have an hour and a half before
you have to leave for work that is a lot
of free that's 20 hours of free time a
week not counting the weekends that's a
lot of free time a ton of
it and if that's what you value most
well that's like the nine
to5 is of all possible options the
easiest
one it's just that it won't make you as
fulfilled probably if you want more
fulfillment you have to do more work if
you want less work you'll get less
fulfillment this is the way life is set
up there is no way around it there just
isn't is it fair I don't know I guess
not is it worth complaining about
probably not can you change it by
complaining definitely not either way
this is life this is what it means to be
a person you have to work one way or
another so make your decision choose
your PA path and get going hey YouTube
thanks for listening to the show if
you'd like access to my full show with
no ads you should go to dailywire.com
and use promo code Walsh to get two
months free on all annual plans see you
there